working within the context of your
ecosystem as indigenous peoples did
instead of trying to disrupt or
manipulate or re-engineer the ecosystem
so I see in modern agriculture with new
biotechnologies certain kinds of
equipment that we're continuing to
redesign and influence the ecosystem
however more and more is becoming not
sustainable for growing populations and
that's a recipe for disaster and so
honoring the differences in our
ecosystems which allows us to farm in
different ways to respect that cuz the
desert in Southwest you know us compared
to Nebraska where I live is completely
different our farm is different from the
calf operations in the Short Grass
Prairie of the Nebraska Sand Hills just
a little ways away is completely
different situation that we're dealing
with and so you got to respect that and
manage based on the types of soils the
kind of rainfalls and what really grows
in your area and so we're learning more
about what Grew From the indigenous
people and then reincorporating that